what was it about them that you wanted
to collaborate with I mean I hadn't met
them but I was obviously a fan of body
and when listened to their other stuff
my agent who's like my best friend
brought up that they were down to work
together and we like set up something
the next day we were just sitting it
instantly felt a connection like hi and
that feeling of like I don't know what
it's gonna be but we're gonna do
something special together just putting
the energy between everyone it's just so
good
[Music]
blast that we saw each other things were
just starting up and body kind of took
over your life didn't it for the better
for the better right I think it was like
you guys were sleeping in one bed at
that time and we were like right it's a
life that's completely we've been
different beds oh good have you a chance
to kind of reflect on that song and what
it's done for your career this year has
just been a whirlwind of like us going
to new places just being all over
meeting new people and yeah that's
gotten us put in the door with a lot of
places that otherwise we would never
even thought we could have been now the
duo are hitting the road for their
nights like this too this is probably
like the craziest thing we've ever done
we're going on tour from now until
December it's gonna be like 60 days or
something like that I think we have like
four days off or something we're going
coast to coast Canada we're doing across
the coast America so we're gonna be
seeing pretty much everywhere yeah and
it's our first time on a bus tour - oh
this is a really big step for us